この対象を拒否する 嫉妬の場合はこういうことなんです
何か見た 何か聞いたって対象が入っちゃうでしょ
その対象はその状態ではいてほしくない
という思う気持ちなんですね
怒りは嫌な味だなと それで終わっちゃいますよ
だから人を見たら嫌な人やと思うくらい動作だけなんですね
それ以上他にこの人はと思うところで嫉妬なんですね
まあ嫉妬はもっと即的に理解した方がいいんです
あんまりこの一番厳密に動作を理解する
ここら辺はまあそんなに大したことないんです
イッサマッチリは というのはまあどうせ嫉妬だから
自分よりちょっといろんな能力を持ってるものやらね
上より人々を見て その人々に対する怒り
嫉妬というものです 自分よりお金持ってる人に対して心に起こる怒りに嫉妬というものです
自分より美しい人に対して
自分の心に生まれる怒りに嫉妬というんです
例えばすごい綺麗な人を見て
ああ すごいいいですね
あんた本当に綺麗で美人でとか思うことは嫉妬じゃないんですね
その人に対して怒るんですね
あまりにも綺麗でとかね
それは嫉妬なんですね
すごくわかりやすいんです
で マッチリっていうのは
そっちで全く逆の働き
自分のものを他人に分けてあげたくない気持ち
例えば自分が人と比べて自分がすごく綺麗美しい
そこで他の人々は自分に酔って酔ってくる
そうするとみんなもうつきなさい
私はもう自分がもうみんなもう追い出されて
自分の美しさは他人に分けてあげたくないというふうな感じなんですね
威張ったりして まあそれは大体あることですね
それはマッチリっていうんですね
大体有名な人々やらね
そういう体の形を売って売って食べてる人々いるでしょ
いわゆる私はもうケチつけて
言葉悪い女優 女優さんやら俳優さんたち
まあ私から見ればただ体の形を売って食べてる人々で
だからまあ一般的に言えば美しい人々だと
結構我が強くて みんな追い出したりして,なんか自分勝手にわがままで生活してるんですね
必ず見えるのはものすごい強烈にわがままと
そこはマッチリなんですね
例えば綺麗な人だからみんな話したがってるんだったら
みんなと話してあげればいいし
一緒に写真撮りたがってる
じゃあいいよとか みんなと一緒に写真撮ろうと
そういう風に自分持ってる
みんないいんじゃないか
みんなという感じにはならない
写真撮るなとかね 使うなとかね
これマネージャー通ってきてください
写真撮るならば その場合はマッチリですね
マッチリは日本語でありますかね
物惜しみ で 暗いんですね
だからすごくいい立派な家を作ったと
鍵やらいっぱいかけちゃって
人が入らないようにする
友達が来てご飯食べてパーティーをやっちゃったら家が汚れるんだからって友達を呼ばないようにする
こんな状態になるの場合は
必ずこの物惜しみの気持ちが働いている
それは怒りから生まれる
嫌だから 分けてあげるのは嫌です
で クックッチャ  4番目のクックッチャ
クックッチャな後悔 語彙は悪さとかいてますけどね
悪さとかいて後悔なんですね
後悔すること で 後悔っていうのは暗いですよ
どうしても で 自分が何かやったことについて悪いことしてしまったなとかね
してしまったなと思っちゃうと
それ嫌でしょ それは だから後悔は怒りに入ってるんです
それは世間ではいいことだと思ってるかもしれません
だけど仏教ではいいことと思ってないんですね
厳密に考え 例えば人をぶん殴ったと
やっぱりやっぱり人をぶん殴って悪いことしちゃったなと
そういうふうに困ってることは
みんな立派な人でね その時はぶん殴ったんだけど
本当に悩んでるんだと
許してあげようとかね
そういう状態はそう思ってますけど
真実のレベルから見るとやったことは嫌だと
やらなかった方が良かったと思う気持ち
ですから その頭に浮かぶ対象はいつでも否定しているんです
拒否しているんです ですから怒りなんです
怒りのグループに入るんです
自分がやったことだから
自分を責めてることだから
後悔だから そこでちょっと食食があるだけ
怒りだけだったらね 例えば何か食べようと思って口に入れたところで
すごい苦くて食べられなかった
それは怒りだけなんですけどね
何かやろうとしたところで
やっぱりあれやらなかった方が良かったと思うと
そこで後悔も付いている
で 後悔はそういうことだから後悔してはいけないんです
後悔するたびに怒りが生まれる
何か悪いことしちゃったら
もうやっぱり明るく もうバカだからやっちゃったんだけど
これで二度とやりませんというふうに
自分がもうやり直すとかね
開き直るというか 開き直るかもかもしれませんだけど
まあ言葉だけだったら反省という言葉はかっこいいんだけど
あんまり意味がないね
反省って言ったって もう後悔と言ったってもね
文字柄に立ったらまあ何なんだ意味がないんだけどね
まあ感情とすると反省は良くて
後悔が悪いと いわゆるポジティブ的で
自分の間違いを考える場合はいいんです
ネガティブ的に考えると怒りなんです
怒りですから 後悔なんですね
ですから 失敗は成功の元だと思っちゃったら
ならば大丈夫なんですね
その間 この間 こういう失敗しちゃったんだから
なるほど分かったぞと
これからはとというならば
その失敗を土台に その人はいい道に行ってるんですね
それは怒りではない で
あのキリスト教でこの自分の罪をなんとかなんとかしてという言葉ありますね
ちゃんと悔い改めてとかね
日本語でそうあってますけど
自分の国の言葉に教教聖書を解釈したところで
その当時の人々はこの後悔という言葉で解釈しちゃったんですね
翻訳したんですね それで大損
全然キリスト教じゃない
今でもその言葉使ってますけどね
綺麗に後悔パスチャータープというスリランカの言葉なんですね
それサンスクリット パーリ語も同じですけど
パスチャーっていうのは後でタープっていうのは悩むと
やってだから後悔でしょ
それはもう明確に罪だと
だからやるなと もうだからそれもあって
また キリスト教の悔い改めるというと
どんな感じかさっぱりわからないんですね
本人たちわかってるのは当たり前だけど
僕らぐらいでも理解させてあげたいんだけどね
さっぱりわからない 何を意味しているかと
何を悪いことした どれぐらい悩めばいいかどうかもね
ですから この仏教と違って悪いことをしちゃったら
すぐ自分ももう立ち直る
やり直す やり直す あるいはまあそれをポジティブ的にこれからやる
わかったぞという感じの生き方に持っていく
こうしたらこうしたらこうなるんだから
もうやらんとそんなことはね
勉強っていうのはそういうものですよ
間違ってる勉強 間違ってる
上から勉強する もう子供たちやってるゲームも同じですから
ゲームやってるといろんなところで敵が出てきて
自分の点数奪ったりして
もう負けたりすると ここら辺ここ気をつけんと
ここら辺ここ気をつけんと
ここら辺ここ気をつけましょうと
子供たちはちゃんとゲームを上手にやってますから
それは明るいんですね
それは人生にもしてほしい
何か間違った しまっちゃった
なんで私はバカなことするんですかというのは
もう完全に怒りの世界
ですから下手な世界 進めない世界
で そうなるんです まずこのセットは怒りのセット
で つも一緒には生まれません
ですから この悪い心というのはそんなに強くないんです
だから動作はいつでもある
怒りが生まれたら動作は確実基本的だからある
それで嫉妬すると動作と嫉妬
物惜しみの場合は動作と物惜しみ
後悔する場合は動作と後悔一緒
いわゆるまあそういうわけで
まあ動作だけだったら動作だけ
そういう風な組み合わせで生まれる
えっと この全部終わろうと思ったんだけど
もうちょっと残ってます
と三つですね じゃあその三つもさっさと言って終わりにしましょう
また後で で ティーナニッダビチギッチャという三つ
そんな説明しなくなってもあんまりいいんですけどね
ティーナは根沈 ニッダは睡眠
ビチギッチャは愚 根沈睡眠愚
で ティーナっていうのはこの根沈睡眠
うーんまあ意味ある ティーナっていうのはなんか自分がすごい
この何て言いますかね
縮むような 精神的に行動的ではなくて
縮むという意味なんですね
控えて縮んで小さくなってとかね
明るくて堂々と胸を張って前向きではなくて
縮んで縮んで下下というふうな
この精神的な状態 いわゆる力がなくなっちゃう心に
それをみんなにこの歩く瞑想でもさせるとよく見えますよ
堂々とこうやって歩かないんですね
すごいかっこ悪いです
ですから そこをなんかどこかで引っかえて
もうね やはりそれはこのティーナが働いてるんですね
だから直すためには もうティーナはわかりませんし
掴めませんし ですから自分の体ぐらいは掴めるんだからね
ですから しっかりと立って
しっかりとこうやって歩くと
結構心もそれに沿ってきて直りますよ
ティーナはそういうことで
ニッダっていうのはもっと鈍くて
まあ寝起ということなんですね
で それはもうほとんど私の定義で
まあアビダンマではもうちょっと違うかな
うんうん 同じだ で 眠くなってしまった
眠くなって行動的じゃない
だから行動するとどんどん明るくなれば暖かくなるということで
スピードはアップになっちゃうんです
人間すごい誤解してますよ
仕事をすれば頑張れば疲れるんだと
それは煩悩ばっかしで欲だけでやってますよ
疲れるんであって 本当は例えば何かこの車があって
この手で回しちゃうんだと
回せば回すほど疲れてスピードダウンになりますか？違うでしょ
回せば回すほどスピードの今まで硬かった車でもどんどん軽くなって回すんだから
それは正しいことなんですよ
で 我々はそうじゃなくて
行動すればするほど疲れて疲れてもうダウンになるのは当たり前でしょうと
だから休まなくちゃいけないんだ
寝なくちゃいけないんだとか
これやり方おかしいし
ですから ティーヌミッと仏教では罪の方に付箋の方に入れてるんです
ティーヌミッと昏沈睡眠は
行動的になれと 行動的になるとベースにどうったことなく
もう何でもやればやるほど元気になるんだからね
暖かくなってるんだから
そこあれば良くないし
瞑想なんかは決してできないし
大体何か行動したくない時は確実にこれ生まれてくる
ですから これも暗いと言えば暗いんです
でも怒りではない 誰かと怒ってるわけじゃなくて
自分でやりたくない それだけ
で ヴィシャッキーッチャというのは疑ですから
疑いなんですね でも疑いという意味というよりは
もう何にもはっきりわからないという心の鈍さなんですね
しっかりした情報やら理屈やら論理とか
そんなことなく私は信じませんよとかね
そういうなんかまあいい加減で気持ち悪い概念なんで
考え状態なんですね いますね
たまに 話も聞きたくないし
信じたくもない 話は聞きたくないんだとか
誰が信じるかそんなもんとかね
そう言ったって あんたちゃんと知ってますかね
知る 知ってもないとか
そういうなんかすごい気持ち悪い性格の人々です
とことん知ってからこれは嘘やというのはわかるですよ
聞きたくない 知りたくもない
信じても信じてもないとか
そんな風にこの どうにもならない
いわゆるこの進化過程
脳細胞の進化はもうストップしている性格
ですから疑というのは
その疑入ったらその人の修行はできません
もう鍵かけてるんだからね
聞きたくはない まあ聞かさら見さるなんとかという状態でも
ですから疑はもう罪ですと
やってみれば別になんでもいいし
もうやったことは嘘だと思ったらそれでやめればいいし
ですから 疑っていうのは自分の心の進歩をストップするということで
はい これで十四は十四の不信称の定義だけはあります
大体これぐらいで終わりましょうか
どうもありがとうございました
はい [ドアを開ける音]